[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
spectacular episode of the careful boys
where
today all right we're going to ask the
awesome question of if you could choose
to be good at any profession without
having to receive the accompanying
education or trade experience which
would you choose
H though they do honestly make B are you
kidding me dude out of anything h y one
of I met this guy cuz we needed to
borrow a car um for a photo shoot and
then I asked this guy I was like what do
you do and uh and then I found out he
was friends with one of my business
mentors one of the guys that started
Hurley and they're neighbors so the guy
that started Hurley he lives in D like
triple gated community in like Dana
Point right and then this guy lives
there too and they end up surfing
together and he has all these cars I was
like what do you do he goes I own an
HVAC company so that's why I was like I
was going to buy one that's [__]
crazy dude yeah well first of all I had
a very good relationship with my HB guy
when I was here in California he's this
Russian dude they wait explain explain
what it is real quick for air
conditioning heating ventilation air
conditioning and like this guy was dope
he could just come to my place and like
because I didn't like you didn't call
ahead and enough to get the apartment
manager to unlock the ladder he would
bring his own ladder he's like no [__]
these people [__] them they'll never
come they never come and all this [__]
that guy yeah he and he would like put
his own ladder there and all [__] by way
just support us in the war he didn't say
that didn't happen yet he sounds like
both sides so then he uh yeah he would
fix my [__] all the time and he's like
he's like whoever did your apartment
they're stupid they're stupid [__] I
hate them like cuz we'd always get this
leak in the ceiling or whatever and he
was like I [__] hate the people who
made your place and and he was so then
by the time it was time to leave yeah
he's always this grizzled guy by the
time it was time to leave because I had
seen him so many times cuz R sucks so
bad he like got kind of emotional when
it was like time to go like I was like
hey dude yeah just so you know this is
probably it cuz like we're we're selling
he's like he's like where are you going
bro I was he's like cuz I think he's
wanted to leave California for so long I
I don't hit it that bad yeah but he was
like he was like I was showing him the
the lakes and all the stuff where we're
going and stuff he's like he's like this
is beautiful this is so I'm I hope you
and your beautiful wife have a great
time he hugged me and [__] wow yeah this
guy made bank and he was like dope and
he was no nonsense and he could work
whenever he wanted or he could tell me
to go [__] myself if he want to and I
still needed him what if he tried to
keep you try to get you to stay like
come on it's not that bad stay in
California it's not that after new some
nothing but if feel was like no it's not
that bad stay it's not the bad he didn't
he didn't think that I just wanted to
try it on are Joe your in
California go the the HVAC company was
going to get us about $4 million they
margins were [__] amazing amazing say
it Russian say it Russian but what was
difficult here is the education so you
are right on the donkey's butt my friend
yes
this so the crazy the the hard part is
that the HVAC are there's so many yeah
it's not just like Toyota Honda and you
know it's like there's you have to learn
so [__] much and there's so many you
know and then different parts and
whatever and the education behind it
it's not like like a cleaning company
right like I mean cleaning it's like you
just come up with your own system and
everyone gets cleaning you can hire
anybody all Ajax whatever but with with
with HVAC you have to
train yeah I'm I'm genuinely surprised
we're just talking about HV that's a
legit professional dude imagine imagine
hooking up your friends it's like dude
your AC is down and your your friends
about to be [__] it's like I got you I
have a friend who's HVAC guy he hooks it
up because HVAC guys are if they're your
friend they can get you the illegal
Freon oh that's tight how do you do make
it extra cold no it's not to make it
extra
cold The Forbidden temperature no
because 50 Decor every every so often
and and they haven't done this in a
while but they'll like the state will
like update the rules on how the air
conditioning should be powered or how it
should work and they'll be like oh that
old Freon 22 is now harmful to the
environment you can't use it no more got
to delete it so now you got to update
your system but then all the ones that
um are grandfathered in still run on it
but they're not allowed to refill so by
the time they finally run out you got to
get a new system so what these guys do
is if you know them they can still give
you the old [__] to refill your expired
because you buy it from a country or a
state that still uh makes Mother Russia
yeah but it's illegal and the tank is a
specific color that stands out so
brightly that he's like if another HVAC
guy sees me holding it he's going to
wrap me out oh wow [__] you know
what the biggest scam is for extra cold
the biggest scam is a lot of our parents
told us to go to college get a degree
and get like a office job all of my
friends who are in like trades and you
know they have um some type of like like
skill in in electrician the
infrastructure jobs they're making
[__] bank they're killing and they
work they work as much as they want to
or as little as they want to they set
their own [__] hours most truck
drivers too man they're [__] killing
it oh and by the way did you guys hear
about this Elon is going to be setting
up a a school like his own school that's
just going to be trades that's cool wow
amazing amazing wow what was the
question
again what U you you be good at any
profession cool about
HB do you want to work on air
conditioners any hot takes on on
H what is a skill you you can do like
that no accompanying education or trade
experience you just wake up it's like
the Matrix is this profession I would
just like
it download it and then now I can do it
yeah but you don't have to invest the
years it takes to like perfect the do
like any type of woodworking or
Contracting like like I would love to be
a guy who could build a with my own bare
hands oh I think that [__] is the
coolest [__] I've ever seen in my life
like every dad the generation prior kind
of for real but like you know like a
master [__] contractor like that
would be [__] sick can I change my
answer yes cuz then in that whole thing
electrical HVAC for like 30 minutes cuz
you could do HVAC in that whole system
yeah and I can maybe do plumbing maybe
you could do electrical architecture
dude you got that's like almost not fair
that's yeah that's too many things
that's too many categories carpentry
though just pick one okay Carpenter okay
either that one or farming like being
able to farm farming like an oh agry boy
huh AG boy so much work you want you
want to be
a I want be you want to be able to grow
your own spinach I want to be a hunter I
don't want to be a gatherer huh gr my
own spinach I'd rather be this guy [__]
you you don't know what you [__] you you
don't know what you're [__] you you
don't know [__] so you just want to be
like magically good at farming like just
anything what's your specialty cilantro
you just got a [__] on the plants and
that's it yeah I don't think that's true
I don't know [__] about farming but I
don't think that's true it is true
Google it do you grow tomatoes with
David go back to no uh [__] no [__] no
you need to taste my tomato I think
carpentry would be tight I'll go
carpentry that be tight hey carpentry is
are really hey don't let us PE pressure
you into a different answer that was my
first answer be a boy you a boy boy Ault
boy oh my God a boy boy did you say you
had one right oh no you said you wanted
to change it you want to change it what
is it now though I want to be a dancer
killer
you only skills that what skills would
you need I don't know I never was born
with that how would you do it would you
a lot of of higher education and trade
experience with this thing it's a huge
Steve would answer I wanted to steal his
answer and then you guys I've never even
heard I've never even heard the term
dancer killer it's a really cool movie
Steve's method would be like two common
words you got to go on LinkedIn more
dude you gather them you hunt them and
then you trap them and then you kill
them Steve would do like a giant like
dance battle with one guy and then out
of his sleeve a little gun would come
out and just shoot him any dancer you
just want all of them to no it' be like
the blade Vampire scene where like out
of the sprinklers comes some kind of
acid and all of them die isn't that
similar to like the gas chamber during
the totally different cuz there's a
bunch of
dancers damn man I think for me it would
be uh be a
doctor damn yeah cuz I don't like the
studying and whatever part but I I think
think it would be cool and like you'd be
an asset to your friends and family if
you knew how the body worked and stuff
so when [__] happens you're like I could
help fix you or whatever you know like
like uh yeah like just be like that that
Medical Aid I feel like you're a doctor
now yo that would be hella funny though
that'd be hella funny if gen granted
your wish and was like you now have your
doctorate and that's it PhD of [__]
flowers or some [__] but you don't have
any skills you just have aor PhD and
flot I would be probably a ER doctor
dang but that's high stress stress
trauma traa huh dude and some days
you're not going to be able to save them
I know cuz the part that inspired me was
uh when taica got his first seizure in
front of me I was laughing and crying at
the same time cuz uh he was put in the
ambulance we didn't know what the [__]
was going on so the ambulance like it
just starts running all the red lights
right and then so they're going I'm
following the ambulance and I was like
the most one of the most traumatic
moments of in my life and I'm like what
the [__] that was [__] crazy that's
my son I never seen that happen and I'm
like dude what do I do for a living I
was like just [__] act like a clown
on like God damn it [__] so I made me go
you feel useless yeah I felt so useless
I couldn't even save my own son what I
going to do Fu like like the wake up man
what you doing don't shake around like
that you know like it's working it's
working tell them jokes yeah so I was
like tell them more jokes so I was like
man it' be tight if knew what to do not
only for my family but other people you
know like at the beach someone collapses
or whatever like you could just help on
the airline you want yeah cuz they go is
there a doctor I go thank God I'm not a
doctor man you have to [__] you you
have an obligation to help somebody
you're on vacation with your
family now you got to work for free
climb over
sleeping no I I flew so much to the
point where like there's probably a
couple people that Di died already I've
heard that multiple times really like is
there a doctor yeah they go they died
already don't worry about it actually
forget that call for a do don't pay
attention to the guy covered in blankets
he's not dead that's what they do bro
really cold and he's sleeping when I was
uh when they did the duct duct and then
like you come in the back of the area
that they said oh doctor here doctor
there and then the doctor's gone right
doctor everywhere there's a blanket over
a person and a seat belt over their
[__] face and you still have to sit
next to them yeah and you're just like
that [__] dead they don't ever
ask for a nurse huh no they say a
medical professional anybody get really
pissed they go Medical Professional not
a nurse don't get up
nurses we need a chiropra CU they could
help too D they do though they do so
yeah whether you're a doctor or nurse
you go up and you show them your card oh
and then the they they have to verify
cuz there's also crazy people that
pretend they're doctors I don't know why
anybody wants to pretend that they're a
doctor but that sh happens right and
then they'll be like I'm a doctor I can
save them and then they have to show the
they have to show the ID card and then
they go okay you're a doctor yeah and
then if they're having a seizure if
they're having anything they have to
verify it's right on the way to Vegas
there was that guy that had the seizure
next to me and then I had to go excuse
me and then they're like stay down we're
we're Landing I'm like no he needs help
yeah yeah that's that's what I would
that would be my answer actually
Chiropractic and acupuncturist really
what that's specific huh how come how
come how come that wow
one because I think it's worked Wonders
on me and I I enjoy like the relas both
well Chiropractic more for like
momentary relief acupuncture is for like
real relief oh interesting I also like
get a kick off of [__] YouTube video
ASMR stuff on Chiropractics when they're
just like cracking [__] and you just get
to cracking hot ladies big ass boobs
yeah everywhere I specifically only want
to have clients that are hot as [__] and
very busty do you like um AK fat dud do
you like acupuncture
ASMR uh that's just painful that's just
ah but but I just do believe in that
actually more acupuncturist but like I
do believe in how that like helps people
and like to be able to administer s
similar things but less stressful
environment yeah you know what's really
[__] funny here is that we have
professions that people dream of right
and then once you achieve that all of
your answers are normal normal jobs I
want to work in construction I just I
want to have a farm I want to be a
doctor like normal [__] jobs right
it's true you guys you guys no longer
dream because my dreams are still
outlandish I want to be a these aren't
our dreams this is just answering the
prom all of us just know how to stick to
a admit it's your dream it's content
Joe all right what's yours yeah but then
okay I'll tell you the chandelier maker
if I didn't have to practice do anything
it would be to be the best pool player
so I could be a pool shark oh that's a
sick one oh dude that's sick you don't
need higher education for that shot by
some guys you know how many hours you
need that you want that to be your
profession yeah dude they be break out
Lucille Jeffrey [__] bust out and
then you oh and then you start [__]
up people pool shark will be L never get
tired of that dude it's Joe's a very
cool guy did you just look over there
and that's your answer trigger a memory
I used to play pull all the yeah cuz I I
didn't know Joe like pulled out yeah you
know that you know where you know where
the [__] uh shooter Mario park
shooting went down I used to go there
all the time and play pool all the time
are you any good at pool no that's why I
wish I
had that's why it's like you know how
many it's [__] dude okay well yeah I
would love to be a professional yeah I
get it well I know you probably will be
one day how come you choose acupuncture
versus do like golfer inspir me I can
tell people what is this
acupuncture you know there's AC you need
acupuncture
probably there's acupuncturist doctors
watching us right now going I wish I had
your job yeah I wish I was a barber yeah
I could be really no oh it's just it's
cool though like there the way to get
there is way harder you got to read all
these [__] books yeah we clowned our
way to where we got that's true yeah I
think I would enjoy the process of
becoming a professional golfer because
even if I sucked and I got good and I
got better and I got better that's still
enjoyable versus like needing to [__]
study every acupressure point and
understanding how to administer that and
doing that in like the high school or
the school functions you know what I
mean like I'd be a professional golfer
announcer and I'd be like he [__]
sucks just anti Anthony right now what
is a very he's got his dream job
already all I guess it's like how many
hours and how hard something is I would
be like maybe engineering or programming
of some sort that's very hard
boring my answer is I would I would be a
hacker a hacker that' be cool then you
could hack anything yeah any profession
i' be a crypto maker
you to wor about anything that's not
really hard anyone cuz hacking's like
that's crazy to be super good at that
and then you can keep it a secret that's
true huh and you will be famous aren you
like halfway there I wish yes see can
you do you code no I can't can't says
the guy who rebuilt Final Fantasy with
all your friends but that's that's
different that's script said the guy who
made notorious [__] GTA tracks that
everybody plays and go that's not even
coding at all it's not cing it but I saw
a hacker documentary on how they recruit
they make you crack a code while someone
gives you a [__] I saw that too is a
docent it's a documentary that a
documentary oh us it's Johnta I think
yep it's a it's a true life story hacker
documentary I think it was Wolverine
actually true life story hacker
documentary cool answer yeah y can we
bring it back to HVAC though yeah let's
go back to H you know what though HV
pretty sick though I I was after I saw
the company's numbers I was so shocked
how much they make and I think the
biggest con here just goes right back
down to like those jobs that are like
people are like you need to get a office
job you wear a suit you can't be [__]
you can't be working on houses and [__]
I was like damn dude that's where the
money was at what the [__] not to brag
probably what I will be known for
finding
gems I knew that about
H just saying okay what's another one
round two everyone go one more time but
you have 30 seconds Max okay um art of
appraiser seems easy like a con job yeah
exactly but then if you're like if you
have the reputation of being a really
good arter praiser I see I mean you just
look at stuff and go yeah it's worth
this much oh you know those guys on on
the tubes who like go to yard sales and
then they resell everything and like
like basically like film themselves
[__] all these people at yard sales
and then reselling everything for like
30X these people at yard sales is like
they're drwing out of their mouths just
hand you stuff for free I'd be one of
those I want to be a light round I I
want to be a yacht Builder Builder which
part of the yacht all of it the whole
the architecting and then the
building okay the lamps the lamps just
the lamp cuz there's people that I have
a friend who only does interior design
for yach Wow but doesn't even know how
to like like the the boy I want a yacht
sales I want to be a yacht salesman
that's a really cute way of saying it
yacht salesman a yacht seller yeah
Anthony lightning round yach than they
sell uh extremely skilled photographer
hey cool I think it would just put me in
really cool life situations that's true
with a lot of hot girls oh wait no not
yeah that's that as well that as well
are we talking about the profession and
actually doing the profession or just
the skills of the profession well being
that in profession that's what I'm
saying if I was extremely skilled then
chances are I'd be like working for
really high some some of these
professions you you can only prove that
you have the skill by reaching the top
of that profession like art appraiser
lifestyle comes with it too I can't just
be good at it in my mind front R for
like sports or like F1 or like [__]
highend fashion or like or really really
hot chicks in really exclusive rich
areas you know start as my professional
in a public place and someone's like we
need an art appraiser emergency we need
AR who's an AR appraiser
oh my vacation dude what's yours what's
your quick one my quick one um I would
do
clamation who I think I always love
clamation I think it's cool wow so you
like G is it cuz of Gumby no it's cuz of
the Rudolph oh yeah do you remember the
Matt TV Rudolphs of course they're great
they real cool yeah but yeah that shit's
cool so would you want to work on Robot
Chicken no oh okay they're his
Rivals we do pure his production has to
be called dancer
killer that's love it I like it actually
love it dance killer ring to it what's
up Nick probably uh probably a chef
that'd be pretty cool what's your
specialty just anything with a walk oh
chines Chef n dude I want to walk the
wave of rice that's like
I really yeah yeah I really like those
dudes that could make like different
types of flavors from different
countries whatever do like a fusion type
of deal yeah you know but like like
upscale like I just love I just love
watching people cook man I'm going to
get a walk in my chef you said what you
should be a [__] Chef oh Malaysian food
court style what about you [__]
[__] I would want to be a Navy
SEAL but I don't want to be at War but I
just like do you want to kill anybody
time Navy SEAL no I like I like that
they can survive anywhere oh part is
cool like throw them anywhere like
[__] in a trash bag like a grill when
they come out they're like yeah easy
that's oh easy mode you're a homeless
man you could survive anywhere about the
actual survival skills they survive
anything yeah but he want a medal though
professional though oh they could be
they could be tied up by the mafia and
they'll survive I know I know you don't
have to be you don't have to kill you
could be a spy they're just professional
tattletails oh like an Intel guy yep
is that exciting enough talking to your
earpiece I want to be like a yeah a bear
of grills he's like special pretty much
yeah go collect Wilderness but he
doesn't want to do the killing part well
then he could be like bear girls where
he's not doing killing but he's so good
at it he's teaching everybody and
there's reality show profal Survivor
yeah why I left JK video
maker and every yeah I make them
all